in your opinion who is kind of like you
know I feel like Memphis is uh you know
it's one of them it's the city in
hip-hop right now um
who's the hottest in Memphis outside of
yourself right now uh
you gotta go with um Chloe for sure it's
big glow right this was so Gloria
she's hilarious for sure you interview
her now yeah yeah I think we ate Edibles
or no we didn't eat Edibles we
I gave her some wax we were [__] hot
it was it was one of the funnier
interviews I've ever done shout out to
Glory yeah I think I saw that you saw a
few clips from me um all right so we got
Polo G we got little Wayne's on the
album right yeah Polo cheese on the
album uh anybody from Memphis
uh
uh I can't get too many so money back
goes on the album
um
I can't get too many I'm Gonna Keep it
fishing no no no April 14. I'm gonna say
no even if you get it right no who is
the what's the name of the title oh yeah
Cottonwood too
there it is yeah sorry I went to April
14th April 14th man uh anything else
coming we've got a remix to do it again
yet
um I got one I did one with a turkey
artist um from Turkey yeah geez what was
that like man it was lit
um he did a very good did he hook you up
with a uh a hair transplant at the same
time nah we we donated some stuff to
Turkey too for the earthquake yeah so it
was real dope shout out to Turkey man
that's also the hair transplant capital
of the world from what I hear
like if you're bald you go to Turkey so
like this guy the senior citizen that's
been taking you to radio stations
he should go to church
he looks like Cuba Gooding Jr let
himself go
yeah
uh time War Two April 14th
uh anything else you got on the way man
uh March 10th you know we dropping um
I'm dropping a new song called more up
front pretty much meaning like you know
the gist of it is if you if you you know
people been showing your word if you
need some more of it you know I'm saying
people been showing you love respect or
whatever you need some more in front of
it you know so that's the gist it's a
it's a banger it's a slapper new records
um hey if you could do a collab album
with anybody outside of Polo G who would
it be
Jerry Drake Drake okay that would be
crazy that'd be hard have you linked
with Drake yet not yet you haven't met
him um we're gonna make that happen oh
me yeah that'd be crazy man all right
well [__] I appreciate you pulling up as
always brother you already know so bro
analy Chopper my bro go get the album
April 14th Cottonwood too